well thanks thanks Andy for that great
introduction just to my timer set so I
don't bore you guys for five hours there
we go I'll do it don't laugh so I really
I really will so okay let's start with
some audience participation
pop quiz what state of the pie what is
the state 5 Texas pecan you guys are
right that is the official state I of
Texas but actually pecan pie is tasty
but it's not what my talk is about I'll
talk about taste later on but not
initially initially what I'm gonna talk
about is on that Andy touched upon which
is sort of looking back at the the
history of pide pide data which is not a
very long history right well I've been
doing this like three years but a lot
has happened in the last three years and
as Andy mentioned we started off even
the first pie data workshop that we did
it was a workshop not a full conference
it was only about you know a handful of
people though that showed up but it was
just something we did at Google Google
headquarters in Mountain View and it was
really really nice
Julie steel from O'Reilly helped us put
it together and we got a lot of
developers in the sci-fi community to
meet with people who were at strata and
it was really nice nice sort of event we
did also confront Google obviously
confront we know about a couple of
things but but we all had a great time
and in the three years since then so
that was the first event in three or
since then we've had quite a few I'm
probably missing some and there's
certainly meetup groups that have sprung
up across the world using the name pie
data and and most of them get in touch
with us and and um focus and and give
you know become connected to the to the
large organization and we have more
coming up more and more companies are
starting to realize that that I data as
an organization um focus as an
organization exists and so it's been
really great and it's great because many
many organizations are using Python
right there's a lot of people who are
using Python all the time and if you
look at this list it's not like marginal
small little you know two guys you know
a you know a little garage startup these
are actually really large companies and
many of them they're not just dabbling
in it right their analysts and data
scientists actively rely on Python and
in many different ways I mean you see up
here
ILM is industrial
magic and and and many of the people in
Hollywood rely on Python to to run the
rendering pipeline so the movies people
don't really talk a lot about that but
it's just the reality on the ground
likewise when you look at some of the
stuff data science especially in the Bay
Area companies a huge portion of that
just runs Python and there's not you
know the thing is that they don't really
tout it you know Python is not this sexy
new bandwagon you get on to get your CIO
all excited it's just a thing you go and
you use and so that's actually a very
interesting thing and and this is what
led to Travis and I actually starting so
really starting that the PI data
conference and trying to create the
nonprofit and get more people involved
around the use of Python for data
science because we saw that many of
these different people you know talk to
data scientist from almost every one of
those organizations and scientists and
just programmers and operations people
over the last three years and talking to
all these people what you see is that
there's some unified challenge
especially the data scientists across
from a bank to the intelligence
community to people working on you know
add analytics to the uber and the
Spotify people like all these folks are
using Python in different ways but
there's some core common challenges that
data scientists have one of them is that
there is legitimately a much larger
volume of data that's coming down the
pike and and everyone is seeing that
it's not just the marketing term as much
as many people don't like the term big
data the reason it's so sticky is
because the fact that it does identify a
real problem people have now the problem
is that big data as a term is not is not
sufficiently concrete for people to know
what kinds of solutions what kinds of
approaches they should take because it's
generally it's just a term that means my
current stuff doesn't work anymore
right my current stuff is broke it's
bigger than Excel and so people then
rush into this market and there's and
what we see is there's just a giant
proliferation there's a mass
proliferation of tools technologies
databases services even trainings and
all these other things that are
happening but really the products and
yeah and the offerings in the space
excuse me getting over this cough so the
the products me offerings in this space
they oftentimes create more integration
headaches they they very very seldom
especially for people with lots of data
and real problems they very seldom can
find
one off-the-shelf product that just fits
their needs and so whatever you buy
whatever you bring in inevitably there's
some integration things that has to be
done and that integration challenge
everyone knows it's there and that is
one of things that actually is a
friction to adoption right so people for
instance with new hardware and new
architectures that are coming down the
pike with SSDs and nvme and then just
GPUs and all these different kinds of
things there's a lot of cool capability
there but people don't even have time to
do the problems they currently have to
go and explore and integrate these new
kinds technologies into their current
back-end and into their workflow is is
almost you know an impossible problem
and of course in you know recognizing
these first three things then there's
many companies and startups coming along
below the way now to that also promise
just one big read solve button or or in
some spaces they would called the one in
the big red predict button and our
prediction button that solved button if
it actually works for you then the
problem is that the your vendor is your
competitor right your vendors not
actually because then you're not adding
any value to the process and so that's
the really big that's the really big
challenge in the space and I think many
of the people again that I talked to
other previous companies on the previous
page here many of them are sort of
reflect these ideas or have even
articulated these ideas to me but these
are the common challenges that people
see across all these different verticals
and there's not really a single you know
silver bullet for all of these things
and what I would say is that you know
when talking to all these different data
scientists I sort of think of them as
bush pilots I don't know people are
familiar with this term how do you know
what this term means bush pilots Wow
awesome
cuz we have great weather for flying
here in Texas right so a bush pilot
essentially just a term for pilots that
fly into places that other more sane
pilots don't fly into so you know
commercial aviation I think like the
world of data warehouses and business
intelligence and all of your master data
management and all of your traditional
data worked you know data oriented
business processing stuff that's a very
very mature field it has tens of
billions of dollars of economic activity
happening in that technology market and
that's like the equivalent of you know
you're like DFW paved runways right and
in a tower to control people landing
bush pilots however they get into play
and they fly wherever they need to and
they land and they deliver stuff that
the people
at their destination need and so
scientists have been in this camp for a
long time we see data scientists now
doing the same thing
there's an entire uncharted continent of
valuable data and analytical routines
and everything
no one has paved a runway there no
commercial 747 is gonna attempt a
landing there there's hurricane force
winds no one flies in there except for
the scientist and data scientists who
just absolutely have to get in there and
so they actually have better piling
techniques than the commercial airliners
where you hit the autopilot once you you
know clear the runway and so what we're
seeing is the reason why so many
interesting tools and open-source Python
are spark to dupe whatever you know you
name it a lot of the open-source tools
are being generated by the people doing
the work because bush pilots are the
ones actually know how to fly right once
you are in a situation where you used to
just buying stuff from a vendor you kind
of forget how to do the engineering of
the stuff underneath and so so the the
the thing I want people to keep in mind
here is we're looking at you know the
later slides and the rest my talk is I
talk about the tools and technologies
these are all coming from people who
have done the work there they're legit
in in the trenches doing the work and
they produce these kinds of tools and so
that really leads to this kind of next
section I wanna talk about which is why
Python why now and and just as a I guess
one one note even though I talk a lot
about Python here I think other other
languages and tools like are in the in
this kind of open source open data
analytic space also fall in the same
kind of category and so I'm just gonna
talk about Python because that's kind of
what I know best but if we look at PI
data and we look at Python you know I
talked about PI data being about three
years old actually PI data is about
twenty years old and all the tools well
almost all the tools and many of the
underlying technologies in the PI data
ecosystem are from the SyFy ecosystem
and from the scientific Python you know
stuff that's been maturing for 15 years
at least and and those things are even
you know built on even earlier things so
the matrix object and numeric those are
very old at this point and those the
ideas from there are still embedded in
the code that many people are writing
today and if not embedded in your code
directly they're embedded in the tools
that your code is using and and this
this age kind of this legacy is not
in any way meant to be sort of
denigrating right I'm not saying the
stuff is old and broke you should go you
something else what I'm saying is that
the sci-fi community in a scientific
Python community they have been
developing these techniques for Bush
piloting right they're developing these
kinds of airplanes and these kinds of
applied into piloting techniques for a
very long time its ground in the history
of like the MATLAB and the Fortran in
the APL world which is really very very
old at this point so when I talk to
people oh you guys can't see that home
it's too bad actually puts Totoro in the
shadow which is really cool but so
there's actually rain you can't see this
I mean you probably infer from the fact
that the little girls holding an
umbrella it's not a big data problem but
uh actually when I talk to people you
know when we go to like the strata and
the big data events things like that a
lot of the marketing literature that you
see from from folks talked about you
know that they use a water metaphor
right that's all volumes of data pouring
down and all this other stuff data Lakes
right data pools things like that and
and and what I sort of you know thought
was a great expression this idea that
Python is a nice umbrella technology
maybe it's a rain jacket that data
scientists like using keeps them dry
less and do their work even as all this
stuff is raining down and so apropos of
the scientific Python stuff really the
reason that the rain jackets the
umbrellas are so good is because the
scientific people the scientific Python
scientific compute the computation
people have been drowning in data for
decades now right so those umbrella
technologies come from like this water
world where these people are building
boats and yes they need a like a rain
jacket because it rains because it's wet
on the ocean but really you know the
idea here is that many of the tools were
using in data science you know the
umbrellas and the things to keep us dry
to let us be agile over data those come
from the world that's just been steeped
in data and high high demands for
computing for a very long time and one
of the things that you know we talk
about big data and talk about the threat
torrents of data and all the stuff and
people talk about how we're in the era
of big data now and I actually really
disagree with that I think we're just
starting on that I think really the
challenge people have is that we're in
the era of broken pcs so the data is big
but that's not actually the problem the
problem is that your current stuff is
broke and when the really big data hits
it's going to be you're just completely
overwhelmed right everyone who's still
using an excel based workflow is too
to be blown out of the water and so
let's talk about broken pcs let's talk
about the PC and how we got here so if
we look at a brief history of computing
very very you guys laugh but it's
actually not that funny maybe I'll make
you cry by three slides in but the but
the thing here is that if you look at
the early history of computing it's not
that long ago that we were starting off
with digital general-purpose computers
as being a new thing and shortly after
we invented Fortran right and then we
invented the semiconductor integrated
circuit so fortunate actually predates
the semiconductor I'll know how many
you'll hear knew that but then
eventually we got to by 1969 we got to
ARPANET which DARPA created in the wake
of actually the sage project and ARPANET
is the precursor to the Internet many of
the ideas mostly ideas behind the
internet arose and ARPANET and what the
lower-right picture shows is a guy named
Doug Engelbart doing this amazing demo
in 1968 it was it's called the mother of
all demos how many people here show of
hands know what that is
okay smattering of people so it's called
the mother of all demos because in 1968
a year before the creation of ARPANET he
demoed a mouse he had Windows he had
video conferencing he had collaborative
editing with hyperlinks in a document
he had a laser light pen he did this
only ten years after they mentioned on
the semiconductor integrated circuit and
and so he's basically doing Google
Hangouts and Google Docs with a light
pen all right 1968 and just this week I
was trying to Google hangout someone on
Chrome and it wouldn't pick up my audio
like it was all weird but 1968 this guy
was doing this so so that all happened a
very long time ago we kind of got to
this point least demonstration of
feasibility as a prototype and then
1970s is where things really accelerated
and we actually lay the groundwork for a
lot of what we had today the C
programming language which we all so
well all of us use one way or another
Ethernet and UNIX which many of us use
directly even if you're using a Mac
you're still using a UNIX right now it's
not Linux but it's still a UNIX and then
Doss which is still at the heart of the
Windows platform was based on CPM which
is great 1974 and by ninety somebody I
would created VisiCalc which is the
precursor to excel I mean we as a
species not I had anything to do with it
but but as a species we figured out that
Excel was kind of a cool thing and that
was 97 you how many people here were
born after 90
7:19 after how many people chef Angie
yeah see so by the time that we like
showed up on earth all the stuff already
existed so what do we had since then
what has happened since then really
right since then it's what I call the
long shadow of 1970s because the the
basically the the popularity of the
personal computer and the dawn of the
personal computing age meant that we
didn't have to do as much hard work on
the backend computing concepts we could
just build applications stick them on a
machine and put that in some place where
it was pen and paper and even the
crummiest application on a four
megahertz chip is better than pen and
paper and so we didn't have to work any
harder than that for a long time and so
we are still living in the long shadow
of 1970s you know if you look the the
you know the Hadoop stack right and a
lot of the Apache stack for big data
based on Java sometimes was invented 20
years ago right and and then we can't
really throw any stones that because
Python was also invented a long time ago
so all of these things were using today
are actually incredibly old and when we
consider the fact that we place our
smart phones every two years right so
this is actually a very very this is
something that I give you sit down and
think about it I think many people would
intellectually be able to arrive at this
but to actually understand viscerally
what it means that we're using 25 year
old technology and we still believe it's
cutting edge what does that really mean
right and and the the reason of going
through this progression here is just to
show that it's not to make people feel
bad but is a show that there was a rapid
progression of stuff happen through the
60s and then it's kind of through the
70s and then we sort of just just slowly
evolved made evolutionary incremental
changes on things so I think part of the
thing part of the reason that that it
that this has happened again is because
software is really effective even bad
software is better than like no software
so that's kind of Marc Andreessen
sovereignty in the world thing but it
does kind of lead us to this question of
like all the new things that people are
excited about people are concerned about
people are talking about reading about
going to you know going to conferences
and learning about how many of these
things are really innovation how many of
them are churn and buy churn I mean
they're hacks around older hacks or in
some cases hacks it on older hacks it on
older hacks but not like drilling to the
bedrock and understanding what is the
real problem here what is the hardware
capable of what is the software capable
of what is
my what am i question I'm trying to ask
what is my task my computing tasks I'm
trying to achieve and how do I build
something around that so these are all
things I think many people looking at
probably not everyone but many people
around the room will look at this list
and understand what I mean by each of
these little bullet points and and has
at least you know dabbled with some of
these technologies and and you look at
this and like are these things
fundamental how many of these things are
fundamental maybe they're fundamental
for certain things but how many of them
do I need to be concerned with if I just
want to get to some business inside at
the end of the day so you know another
another thing that we can look at is
when we look at all of the
virtualization you know in a different
way looking at the the software stack
just the software stack side of things
we have so many different kinds
technologies coming around as the
browser as browser runtimes become very
fast and become you know in the
forefront of people's minds there are a
lot of things hitting JavaScript a lot
of things on virtualization all of these
different things it really it's like
it's a technology soup but it's also
there's something deeper there there's a
kind of deeper sort of I think just
quiet you know sort of I've always loved
that picture when people talk about
containers and Dockers and vagrants and
all these other things like at some
point there is something hitting the
water there's bare metal somewhere but
you don't know exactly where that stack
you are sometimes but really I would say
that is right now when we look at you
know the Python land and some of the
tools and some of the arguments and
discussions happening around Python
technology whether it's packaging
whether it's the JIT whether it's async
i/o and parallelization whether it's the
Gil all of these different conversations
that we have in Python land all of them
are actually they reflect the evolution
the underlying technology space itself
and and my my overall broad brush kind
of view of that is that we're moving
from being you know the early days of
computing were around hardware people
built better hardware that would make
hardware startups to build chips that
did something and then at some point the
hardware became good enough to where
people could build software and Bill
Gates invented the concept of charging
for software and made a lot of money
doing it and so we had years and years
decades of people building just software
and at some point when the software
churned when the software is good enough
and there's too much turn there people
be concerned about then we can layer on
top of that cloud service as a certain
kind of services here I don't mean like
professional services consulting I mean
services endpoints things like that and
so I think that's the evolution we're
kind of getting to and when you look at
the tool
orchestration DevOps those sorts of
things they're really trying to get
themselves away from that churn they
want to insulate that these are
developers who want to insulate
themselves away from the churn and the
hardware in the software space and
really just get to a point where they
can offer a rest endpoint or a front end
you know browser or mobile visible
application and so they're they're
really not about software development at
that point they're really about
deploying services so so there's a lot
of blurring there's a lot of blurring
and confusion I think in the software
space because it's bifurcating there's
some people who still really want to do
software and there's other people who
really want to build services and see
software as a means to services imagine
if sava developers went and started
soldering things they're not really
hardware hackers that are like hardware
people there are hardware engineers but
they can just kind of solder enough
things and drop enough chips in enough
places to make something basically work
and that's kind of what we see DevOps
found the pressure on DevOps into the
orchestration and the IT system in space
so a lot of the stuff though is again
the the the the whole point of this last
several slides here is to get people to
understand
I guess my perspective that the the
confusion or the the churn in the
software space really comes from the
fact that the underlying bedrock of
computing that's been there for the last
35 40 years is changing out that that
we're coming to the end of of the PC era
and I have I saw this really really
amazing quote
a few weeks back someone said that you
know the way we think about concurrency
is still slave to abstractions from
1970s and it's really true they're
talking about threads and they're
talking about assuming you know threads
prosity stacks and and and all sockets
and all these things these are all
concepts and then in the 70s when we
literally had like a small
microprocessor and maybe a spinning
platter right so that's that's really
something for people to keep in mind I
think especially as we're looking at the
the data world and and how we want to
use computing to solve data problems
right we're not trying to just build
software we want to actually deliver
business value or deliver insight to our
upstream into the rest of organization
and so what I would like to ask the
question of is you know how do we
actually go and go and build on the
ideas from the 60s how do we go even
further forward and build in 1967 1970 s
because the 1960s
when they really had a lot of the
challenges that we're having now they
had a lot of compute relatively speaking
and a lot of storage relatively speaking
and not much bandwidth between them and
they had a lot of people with really
interesting questions while interesting
then relatively speaking that couldn't
be expressed quite natively in machine
code on some of the really jakie
hardware they had so we really need to
go back to those ideas and think about
how people did computing in a way that
was bandwidth aware that was IO
bandwidth and and really focus on on
those kinds of questions so when I gave
my keynote at PETA in New York in 2013 I
talked about how we're approaching this
from the Python land what continuum is
trying to do and and all the various
technologies that we see coming out of
the Python ecosystem and really it's
around you sort of see in some of these
maybe you can't see it because these
pictures are very obscure but
essentially I was talking about the
various layers of abstraction that we've
built up over the years and then talking
about how we want to move to a point
where we're taking a high-level language
that is close to the domain expert close
to the data scientist or the scientist
and then we lower their questions down
dynamically to whatever hardware or even
layer it on top of whatever data
architecture they have and the pictures
in the middle are really just kind of
deconstructing this idea of what a PC
really is so that videos up on YouTube
if you guys want to go and see it and
get kind of a deep dive on this
deconstruction of a computer
deconstruction of computing and software
but but but you know one of the key
things we need to do with Python is
actually make it better glue so the
reason that we see Python uses so many
of those places that I showed kind of
one of the first slides is because no
matter how many new technologies come
along no matter how many different ends
of questions you have at some point
you're going to be able to take your
code your ideas and Python your
knowledge and expertise you've built up
around Python and hit that particular
back end or talk to that particular
database and that's what actually been
you know in the early 90s or sorry in
the early 2000s the the conversation on
Python was really about Python is a
great cool language you can do you know
like a web script in it you can go and
do some mail processing script you can
even do science you know like that was
conversation around Python as glue and I
think that we're looking at you know
looking forward to Python being glue 2.0
not so much for like replacing bash
scripts some Perl
things like that but in the data science
side of the world and the data copy and
the computational science side of the
world
I think this legacy is a blue language
needs to be extended by actually looking
at what the next gen blue needs to be
and it needs to be centered around this
idea of connecting data silos as opposed
to moving data around a lot of the
technologies that don't work very well
right now are centered around the idea
of moving moving data around and the
scientific computing people and the
really high-performance computation
people have known for a long time that
you can't do that you really have to
move your code to data but it's very
important that you move the right coated
data if you're moving very very
low-level software engineer generated
Java code that really doesn't answer the
domain problem then it's no good to move
that code you really want the the data
aware person the person who is aware of
the the statistical problems in the date
of the question they want to ask are at
this very high domain oriented level you
want those people to take their ideas
and put those in the code so you really
want to connect that end-to-end and so
that's actually at the heart of one of
the one of the DARPA funded we have
three DARPA funded projects that we're
doing continuum one of the the key ones
that's you know been incubating for a
long time now but is really coming into
its own and in recent in the recent year
it's it's a project called blaze and
what we're really trying to do is
deconstruct the actually my last slide
here the transcend legacy model of
computation so it's really about trying
to to transcend or deconstruct that by
giving people the ability to express
their questions talk about the schema or
the metadata around of their data and
and then also describe the computational
back end or the computational
infrastructure they want to run on and
be able to do all of these things in a
first-class way many systems nowadays
especially for big data or whatever they
sort of merge two of these concerns
along one one of these edges and we
really want to get to a point where the
Python programmer can write some kind of
expression you know join this group by
that do this kind of aggregation filter
out with this predicate and write that
expression at once
and then be able to run it on a pile of
CSVs on disk or be able to run it on a
sequel database of some sort or go and
move it to PI spark on their Hadoop data
or whatever but they
their problem once and if their data is
stored as a CSV file on disk or if it's
unloaded to park hae-in hdf5 an HDFS
they can oh they only have described the
schema of that data once and so really
the separation of these three things I
sort of like it it to splitting the atom
it's a very difficult thing to do well
because you can very quickly find
yourself writing a new compiler very
quickly find yourself writing a new
database system none of those things are
really that great to do as a bootstrap
startup because those are very expensive
things tend to do well but what we want
to do is just get it so that people can
express their ideas the people who have
the the most insightful questions the
most domain oriented questions can
express their ideas in a high-level way
so now back to that taste question how
many people will so taste is actually an
anagram of state but I don't have any
bloat around for this oh my gosh for
Steve that's actually Steve Jobs looking
incredibly arrogant as he talks to the
reporter here the interviewer about you
know the the only problem I curse offed
is that they just have no taste and I
don't mean that in the rest of the code
is I don't mean that in a small way I
mean that in a big way okay so who Steve
jaws riffing this is I this is this is
before Microsoft bailed out Apple
actually but but but he what he was to
say about this though a lot of you
getting flack about this right and
sowing Oh Steve Jonathan arrogant but
what he's trying to say here is that the
people who made the most money off of
the PC revolution which was not Apple
actually but all the clone makers the
Dells the IBM's and then the Microsoft's
and software vendors on top of that they
were rapidly trying to do his land grab
and they're just building out whatever
to do whatever to solve people's
problems but they didn't really sit back
and contemplate from you know a position
that only Steve Jobs can apparently
about you know the N F of equalities
that makes something that make sort of
something appealing and useful and then
also captures an emotional bond between
the user and the community device like
Steve really saw computers as Steve Jobs
I don't know personally but Steve Jobs
saw computers as being consumer devices
they're they're really devices that
people should be using their human
devices and so what do you mean by this
with that they were just building out
for the
like Microsoft and the others they were
just building software just throwing
parts and chips around to build
something for a use case but not really
considering the connection between the
user the the end person themselves and
the object right and so this of course
now in hindsight we recognized that the
genius the particular genius of this and
recognizing that there was a consumer
digital revolution happening and so
starting with the iPod and then the
iPhone it's on and so forth sort of led
to a renaissance in Apple Apple Computer
and I look around to see a lot of
glowing apples here right many of you
are probably using the command line
using the UNIX level interface on your
machines but it's so very nice hardware
and that connection that taste is what
Steve was really talking about here and
so despite kind of the arrogant
posturing of this there's actually a
really interesting kernel of an idea
there which is that you really want to
get the technology close to the end user
and so we believe that Python actually
has a similar kind of I would say
aesthetic but there's similar kind of
connection in that when we look around
at the kinds of people who are writing
code or the kind of people who in any
way intersect with code there's many
people never touch code at all they you
know snapshot on their phones they look
up recipes on a browser but they never
actually go and touch a line of code
change a function anywhere and if we
look at the special people who can touch
code there's kind of a very obviously
very broad spectrum but on the one side
we have what I would call analysts
they're people who are using Excel maybe
using advanced Excel with macros and
things maybe they're writing some VBA
maybe not maybe they're just clicking
some formula and changing out some value
they're really kind of end-user analysts
but what they do all right what they're
getting paid for and often times get
paid very well for is they deliver
business insight they deliver insight to
their organization right and by this is
why I say business here I really mean
generically you know if you're a
non-profit Research Center if you're a
government research lab it's still the
same kind of thing you have an
organization that actually has questions
and you need insight and so people who
drive Excel excels most popular data
analysis platform in the world and it's
because it's basically at that 80% you
know preeto optimal it just gets you
your answers quickly they might not be
the most accurate answers you may be
lying to yourself but it still get you
an answer that you can then you know
with plausible deniability hand officer
else now on the programmer side we laugh
but we really should be crying cuz we
all know it's true right on the
programmer side on the programmer side
we have software developers who you know
they're told they should learn a new
language every year they get berated you
know by various tech blogs about how
they should be constantly keeping their
skills sharp learning you know whether
it's rust or Nimrod or go or closure or
whatever it is they're learning this
year there's always some new technology
they need to be on the edge of and
there's a sort of an egoism kind of
thing there around that but ultimately
the reasons because their skills and
their tools are around the production of
code they get paid to make code that
works now what it actually does when
it's working is sort of not the not
totally there department right that's
sort of the people who through the spec
over the fence the program manager who
Specht out the product but ultimately
the the programmer in the trenches their
day-to-day is punching code into a text
editor somewhere and then making that
thing work and in the middle we have an
emerging middle class of folks that
write code and and don't really want to
be writing code or you know want to
write less code or want to be more
efficient at actually getting to the end
result of what the code gives them and
and maybe the best way to sort of
articulate this is that the programmer
sees software as an end unto itself and
the people in the middle see software as
a means to an end if you on the Left
don't see software at all right they
don't really intersect with software
people in the middle though they see the
software they can see the code they can
edit the code but really that's what
they really want to be doing is
answering the questions and and building
prettier visualizations and all these
various things and so those people in
the middle have you know each of these
different tiers of folks have their
go-to tools people on the right that's
your traditional Java c-sharp C++
JavaScript web programmer Ruby on Rails
etc on the left these people are using
kind of point-and-click II sort of tools
and in the middle we have people using
SAS and R or MATLAB Python and what's
interesting what I sort of I've
identified at least in my travels is
that Python actually crosses the
spectrum here pretty well it doesn't get
all the way to the far left edge you
know your your actual end user a person
who only knows Excel they're gonna be a
little intimidated when they see just
all this Python code even that's really
readable on the right-hand side your
people who are hardcore you know
embedding assembly in the middle there's
C code they're not gonna go to Python
even
they sometimes should for performance
they really wanted cranking out that
machine code and what we do see is that
having Python having a single language
that can cross these technical
boundaries and really craftsman
boundaries right all these different
people are crafting something of a sort
and so having one technology platform
one technology ecosystem that that all
these people can come to is actually a
really really interesting sort of
situation because now your end user can
talk about your data analyst can
actually articulate what they want and
maybe a high level way maybe not the
most efficient but they can take that
and take those ideas and pass them off
to someone who can then do the low level
engineering pieces they can say well I'm
looking at your routine here I don't
really know the math of why this is why
you divided by two pi over here I don't
know but I can tell you that right here
you should be using a for loop
you should call out to this thing which
then paralyzed over the GPU right but to
have the same code base to have the same
technology suite that all these people
can be talking on talking about and
talking within is incredibly powerful
and that's why so many people that we
talk to so many small organizations
standardize on one or two kinds of
platforms like this we oftentimes see R
and SAS and MATLAB being used in
conjunction with Python but but there's
still a large group of people who are
using Python taking those ideas and
re-express in them in Python so then
those ideas can bridge the gap between
the end-user VP c-level person to the
low-level ops person who needs to go and
deploy the Python on the linux cluster
so that and at least the kind of this
next again about the whole concept of
taste and about that connecting the end
user the reason why intersecting all
these three having you know sort of
having a projection into all three of
these tiers is it really really
important is because this really lovely
Venn diagram that I saw recently I don't
have people in the back and see it but
the top the top circle the blue circle
his subject matter expertise the left
one lower left the blue circle is
critical thinking of high statistics and
the lower right is access to tools and
and these are not exactly the terms I
would use but they're pretty close and
so the idea is that if you know some if
you have the subject matter expertise
and you have critical thinking apply
statistics you you that's great
both of those but you have an inability
to execute right you have this really
great idea you know something about the
domain you know how to do this amazing
stencil modeling and you don't know how
to run it on the 10000 course that it
would need to to actually do this at
scale on the bottom connection if you
have access to the tools and you have
the critical thinking and the apply
statistics but you don't actually know
the domain you can do a lot of like
cool-looking things but ultimately
they're irrelevant your conclusions are
relevant because a business person
actually knew something about the domain
who knew about power engineering who
knew about you know human movement and
you know video surveillance whatever
they could have told you before you've
encoded a single line of code that the
question you're asking was irrelevant
right and likewise on the right hand
side if you have the subdivided
expertise and you have access to tools
you can go and code a bunch of stuff and
click around a bunch of like machine
learning things but you don't actually
know the right inferences to draw from
that you can lead and lead you to
incorrect conclusions and so really at
the center of all three of these you
have a sweet spot and so what we're
seeing definitely when we talk to data
scientists of smaller organizations they
really become the Nexus the place where
this stuff comes together we have the
business people with the questions the
technology people who know how to deploy
this you know at scale and and then they
can onboard a lot of deep deep you know
statisticians and deep you know
mathematical modelers to go and tackle a
problem it's so it's very very
interesting and the tool of course that
we see people using there a lot is
Python because they calls in there's
sort of a correlation there so it's not
but our selection bias whatever but um
but definitely people are using Python
to to use that as a tool in the middle
and really the the the point I like to
make is that there's this it's not just
about art you know can you sling code
right if you want to build a mobile web
app if you want to go and build a
website with something or the other you
can go and do that with Python you can
write some Python scripts to orchestrate
and and you know configure a cluster of
machines but really the the pythons use
in data and computational science is
really driving towards what I think of
as a kind of this idea of data literacy
and so you know when I was growing up
and in high school there was these like
business leadership classes and
everything in business technology
classes and school and I never took them
but I would see the people going in
there and all they would do is typing
they would learn a little excel and they
will learn to type
and like that's not business that's not
computing skills that's keyboarding
skills it's not computing skills the
same thing here right typing and basic
like how to operate how to close a
window how to double click a link these
are things that we don't even teach
anymore people doesn't know them but
those things are just they fade in the
background they're how we do our work
and I think that data exploration and
data analysis in the coming sort of
water world that we're going to be
living in this that the tsunami of data
coming down on every single vertical in
that world data exploration and agile
data analysis is going to be a survival
skill it's gonna be as core a skill as
just literacy and so I call that data
literacy and the thing about literacy
it's interesting right I mean it's it's
the word literate is really around the
idea of language around the idea of
being able to express your ideas and and
I think that language is you know I
don't just think I mean clearly language
is a human instinct I've like a
one-year-old and she's got language
right but when we talk to Python users
and we talk to people just casually at
meetups things like that
a lot of people are passionate about
Python because they feel like they can
actually express themselves they feel
like they're actually agile over their
problem domain and that feeling of
agility is is actually um it's it's it's
really ineffable it's or like this taste
is it sort of the I so I would say that
agility is the analog of taste as as
Steve Jobs talked about you know how
computers related to consumer digital
agility and and fluidity and
expressiveness these are things that are
really hard to capture but when you've
got it it's really hard to survive
without it
right when I was at the New York City
High day to meet up and I just it was a
host at Bloomberg that had a wonderful
event and one of their newly hard
machine learning experts came up to me
he was kind of the older gentleman you
know very very well-spoken and and
clearly a sharp guy but he said to me
that you know he was looking around and
of course as a machine-learning guy in
New York can get a job right so he was
like he's looking around he was
interviewing with Bloomberg and he
basically said to them okay here's my
stipulation the salary is great all
that's great but here's my stipulation I
have people to use Python and on top of
that I have to really use anaconda so if
you make me use some other thing I have
to go and like try to build all this
crap I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna
take a job and so obviously personally I
found that very validating but but it
was just really cool right and actually
he's the other cool I don't remember
that
daughter was going to was just starting
in psychology something in at Cornell
and so they were using are in the the
Mahabharat because a lot of the stat
stuff is not in our but additionally she
was also having to learn Python because
that's what they were teaching kind of
just everyone in the university at the
intro CS and so that was very
interesting thing for me as well to see
but but in general the idea here is that
that agility and that that
expressiveness like how many people here
if you could not use Python if you're
excited I'll Python not you could not
use Python would you actually start
looking for a different job maybe if
you're sitting next your boss to not
have to raise your hand but I'm just
kind of curious like I'm just kind of
curious about that right because that's
even if you don't raise your hand like I
want you to think about that because at
this point if you're doing data science
if you're doing any kind of data
analytics visualization you can pretty
much get a job there's a lot of demand
right the job mark is really hot but but
when you have that kind of opportunity
then it's time to get a little bit maybe
pickier or you know more Steve Jobs like
about the tools we use and if we can't
use the tools that we are familiar with
that we like then how do we improve that
situation right and and so what that
really ties into and segues to what I
see as the mission for my company and
and I think really for the community as
a whole is that we want to empower the
analysts and data scientists to be able
to explore their data and to analyze
their problems but we also want we also
want them to be able to share their
results and we really want them to be
able to connect with other people who
are doing similar work we want them to
learn from each other we want them to
teach each other and in teaching of
course you learn as well and so if we're
really on the edge of this era of
ubiquitous data a lot of these
traditional software ecosystems and even
Hardware things are gonna get blown
apart and so in Tangled
kind of it's like just mess that's that
remains after that I think a lot of new
business models are gonna emerge you
know just like social and mobile emerged
as new entire areas technology very
recently I think that data services data
platforms data companies data startups
all those things I think many people
here probably see that I don't have to
do a lot of you know advocacy of at this
point but in other other circles I do
but I think I'm gonna see a lot of new
business models and new ways of doing
making money off technology that doesn't
involve just coding or just building
chips and so what we want to do is make
sure that people are doing that our most
effectively able to to pursue their
particular business goals and and take a
lot of the pain off their play a lot of
data munging a lot of the rote
deployment and configuration and all the
other stuff get all that off the plate
and we really think that those
foundations though you know obviously
many people would love to do that as
well in this kind of opportunity but we
think that would be really really
unfortunate it'll be very limiting if
that were done in the closed-source way
that were done in a way that closed off
innovation or just put a rent-seeking
sort of gate on innovation and so we
really want to build an open foundation
for those sorts of things that's why we
as actually if you look at the number
there's a lot of other languages right
the our folks are involved julia is
involved many things that we do in the
Python land now especially as it faces
modern data science our polyglot so the
beaker notebook has a polyglot ipython
notebook now Jupiter is polyglot lots of
different languages Scala Python are
julia bring-bring whatever you got right
and the reason is because we care more
about that connection and connecting on
open open foundations we think that's
gonna lead to a exponential increase in
innovation and an exponential increase
in opportunity for everyone
and when I talk about open though it's
very very I've just now started to
realize how important it is to
articulate what it means to be open in
different ways for different people so
for a geek you know when you think
open-source you think probably oh it's
licenses MIT Apache you know BSD or GPL
or some other goofy licenses something I
did but but it's really about the fact
that I can take it I can fork it build
software involve all the stuff and and
that's that's certainly a part of it but
I think really why people geeks at least
are interested in excited open-source is
because for them
open-source tends to strongly correlate
to innovation it strongly correlates to
people who just had to solve their own
problems so badly they went and built
their own back scratcher right and so
that's the articulation of the
open-source the open-source foundation
has articulate for a very long time the
idea of people scratching their own
itches as opposed to a vendor selling
you a back scratcher which they're you
know market research team told them
would target where they think your back
is itching right actually there's a guy
who's really itching
like me and he's got the stick he's
using I'm gonna take that fork that
stick actually works fork that stick and
then you know use it myself
and so so it ties into the the utility
of it the value in the innovation but
also the community and the ethos in the
culture around that that people are
going to talk to you about their code
they're not gonna go and you know just
shut you down and it's all so forth and
so that really I think for geeks is the
value of open-source now when you talk
to when you talk to what we can you know
not pejoratively but what geeks tend to
call suits right people who actually
understand business problems who have
money maybe wish have better terms for
them but when you talk to the suits
about about open source a lot of times
now at this point people are deploying
on Linux they're using open source tools
like Hadoop and Python and are they
understand that open source is not some
scary sketchy people in a basement you
know like whatever kind of thing but
they really focus on the cost and the
value the ROI can I get vendor support
is there as actually I talked I was
talking to a banker yesterday and now
two days ago it had a really great
expression he's like I need a throat to
throttle right when things go wrong he's
British and says I need a throat to
throttle great term and yeah actually if
you're watching this hi Brendan so
anyway so the idea here is that that's
what they're focusing on it's again
about the cost and the thing but what I
think we should articulate better as
geeks as data scientist as people doing
the work when we talk to our business
side folks the folks who have the budget
and our CIOs are making technology
decisions we really should frame the
conversation not around the cheapness
of open source around the innovation the
fact that it's being done by people who
are trying to solve the problems
therefore it is tied to the edge of
innovation and right now because we're
not in a stagnant you know 1970s era
thing anymore because things are just
constantly coming out new sorts of stuff
are happening all the time we are it's
it's incredibly important for people to
stay plugged in to that edge of
innovation and so at the end of the day
you know I was talking to a guy who just
had started at a three-letter agency and
it was really interesting he was just
starting learned Python really cool guy
has a mechanical engineering background
and and we started talking about this
stuff actually Ben was there right
here yeah we're having nice conversation
that guy and occurred to me as we were
just chatting over beers that really
this idea that you know tooling is a
culture like the tools that you use and
the way you use the tools languages
obviously form cultures but really tools
form cultures and what we really see as
we've been doing all these PI data as
people create their own PI data meetups
and and talk about the things they're
doing we're seeing a lot of people
coming out of the woodwork so to speak
who have been using these tools and who
are realizing all the sudden that
they're not the only ones with this
particular problem the only ones who is
sort of like got the same WTF like it's
really deeply validating actually when
you're just one or two people in an
organization a large organization to be
able to go to a place and find out that
there's other people like you and that's
like a lot of the value of the PI data
of conferences and meetups that's that's
really why we put so much effort in to
creating the foundation to get more
tools and to get more people supported
more the developers and you know a lot
of the people who are hacking on these
tools or grad students getting them
support getting them to these places to
connect with their users all of that
community building is deeply
structurally almost existentially
critical to the success of these tools
and so my admonition for all of you my
charge to all of you is to connect with
each other and to make the effort to go
to a meet-up
to go and if there's no one for three
meetups in a row talking about how a
particulars tool being is being used in
a particular way go in and offer to
speak even just a fifteen-minute little
lightning talk or five minute like my
line he talks for 15 minutes but other
people their lightning talks maybe five
minutes I'll talk just on hey I'm using
this tool to do this if you guys are
doing this to anywhere out in the
audience come talk to me afterwards
right we'll chat that kind of community
building that kind of connection is what
is going to create the substrate for
this kind of open innovation and so that
is my my personal charts all of you
hopefully all you have sort of can
appreciate that many of the tools you're
using here many of tools that were
presenting here are created by other
people who are just like you who had
problems just like you did and who sat
down paying things out over weekend
Travis Oliphant who's not here you know
he basically spent a year building out
numpy and we are all really standing the
shoulder of that particular giant and
then of course it's a very large
ecosystem community maintained effort at
this point but we're standing on those
shoulders
because individuals went and did them
they took the effort to build things to
submit bug reports to you know submit a
pull request and try to fix things if
there's things you like in this world
then in this inner world elite not just
in the world generally but in this world
around the Python world I'd strongly
encourage all of you to get to get
involved in whatever way you can you
know at the end of the day pie data is
not just like a conference or meet up
and Python isn't just a language it
really this entire open-source movement
around open data analytics at this point
we have a moment to create an open
foundation for all this stuff and it
really fundamentally is about changing
the culture of how data and analysis is
done and data processing and data
analytics is done and I would invite all
of you to kind of be part of that
cultural movement so thank you very much
we have a little bit of time for
questions but before we go IV remiss if
I didn't mention that continuum is
hiring and we're also selling as a
founder I have to do this so anyway
please email me follow me on Twitter
reach out to me on LinkedIn or whatever
but maybe you have time for like a
couple of questions thank you